[Music]
there is a glitch in the new madden 15
NFL video game a rookie linebacker named
Christian Kirksey who is in real life
six foot two was accidentally made one
foot two by the game's programmers this
we didn't make this up this is real here
he is in action in the video game a lot
of people talking about this
[Applause]
it's hilarious it's really funny
everybody's talking about it big in the
gaming world so I thought we should
bring them out here on the show latest
um in Christian Kirk's Ephraim Madden 15
let's get him out
[Applause]
[Applause]
I know he's not very fast no no not at
all
we got a big show to do we got a big
show to do we don't have time for this
right now Christian we gotta go I'm
sorry we got to go we got ya
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that little guy hey to kick them uh
excellent show tonight very talented
gentleman here a star of the HBO series
the leftovers I don't if you're watching
the show I absolutely love it
Justin Theroux
[Applause]
chica
we're going to see illusion you gotta
tell me if you're gonna get out long
enough try the next one
from Arrested Development and the HBO
series veep Emmy award-winning actor
Tony hey
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I didn't see you ever hurt me it's your
good foot
[Applause]
down here I pick the one guy in the
audience who's got a bad knee is your
knee okay sir yeah okay I'm really sorry
I at random pick a guy and I made you
give me what three standing ovations
[Applause]
playing basketball do you want to try
and minion kick the football player with
a good knee or would you rather not okay
give it a shot I think it's right around
here and I'll tell you when to go and
[Applause]
[Music]
sorry
I'm Safi boy do I know how to pick up
hey you do some jumping jacks
you